hello friends I'm Ilana and welcome to
my channel today I am talking about a
real thing that is actually happening
somehow well no not somehow I know
exactly how it's happening but wow I
can't believe this is real
some of you may have heard like a tidbit
of this but I feel like it's only been
based on one announcement that a couple
of sites covet not everyone and this is
probably going to be a huge thing but I
feel like not a lot of people know about
that was a bad intro really danced
around that one didn't we
coronavirus you've probably heard of it
devastatingly not related to the beer
con imagine what it's doing for their
marketing though
so the coronavirus for anyone who
doesn't know is a virus that broke out
in China and has since spread to a
couple of other countries it most
recently led to PlayStation and Facebook
both pulling out of packs and GDC PAX
East specifically which is in Boston
where there was one confirmed case and
then GDC which is in San Francisco which
is a lot weirder considering both
companies have headquarters in that area
anyway for my general understanding of
the corporate structure the games
industry that whole side of it is really
just because if one person does get sick
with the coronavirus and it becomes a
serious issue or they die which is still
very unlikely they could be sued for
sending employees there because America
one of the things that you may know is
before it disappears I forgot that I'm
using a green screen for a brief second
there this one is the thing that was
covered the corona virus delayed the
launch of the outer world that is the
switch port specifically this happened
because vertuous who is the company who
is handy handling the port and actually
handles a lot of ports in the games
industry which is largely what this
video is going to be about I don't think
people realize quite how few companies
actually handle their own ports like
in-house in the local dev team
headquarters they are generally covered
by someone in China I mean or kuala
lumpar there are like a lot of different
places that have these huge studios that
handle ports that often also work on the
main games but never really get spoken
about so virtue O's has the largest
office in Shanghai in China I believe
it's like the Chang Ning district
and to combat the coronavirus employees
have been working from home this is from
the virtuous Facebook page as the
outbreak of the corona virus has
dominated the news recently some of you
may be wondering about the current
situation in China and what by choice is
doing about it all staff a while
unaccounted for no signs of infection in
general they're a little stressed less
than 35% of a-ha our staff have traveled
to a high-risk area in late January the
Chinese government extended the Chinese
New Year holidays until February 2nd to
keep people kind of out of work Shanghai
government extended until February 9th
there is reduced local transportation
making it difficult to people to even
get to work either and so virtuous as a
result of that also decided to extend
their holidays until the 9th along with
the Shanghai government it says our
client should therefore expect a at
least a week's delay in deliveries they
then updated on February 5th saying we
posted an update about the corona virus
outbreak here's how we're dealing with
it some stuff working from home and they
have you know web discussions etc to
keep things on track but basically the
outer worlds switchport was delayed
because of the corona virus and so has
production delays for the Nintendo
switch itself
did that sentence make sense they have
also been production delays for this
which is what I tried to say that that
is because they have production for the
Nintendo switch joique on controllers
and ring fit ventia in China actually
96% of Nintendo Sony and Microsoft
consoles are made in China intend oh
said production ship and delays will be
inevitable for peripheral devices such
as an antenna switch enjoy Khan
manufactured in China for the Japanese
domestic market obviously same as ring
for adventure so the thing about this
and if you look at sort of what China
looks like while the corona virus
outbreak is going down
what an awful ad this is what the
streets of Shanghai actually have looked
like with the corona virus which I guess
at the time of this being published that
affected 73,000 people globally but it's
basically just very empty and very
protected just public areas that would
usually be full of people have
absolutely nobody in them it's pretty
insane
to give you more detail on how much of
the video game industry is Chinese or at
least how many games that you know
Triple A video games are actually in
significant pot made in China
this article by the future wraps it up
really really really well so virtuous
who is the company is handling who is
handling the switch port for the outer
worlds build 3d art and levels for the
biggest video in companies in the world
Sony Microsoft an EA among others they
worked on horizon zero dawn for example
they also worked on Star Wars
Battlefront 2 I mean they walk on
Studios like this which they don't like
the word outsourcing because I guess
that implies something negative people
don't like calling it like an asset flip
company even though these employees are
being paid like $10,000 a month which
seems just insane to work in China it
has more looked at as a global effort to
develop a video game rather than yeah we
made China make the environments but
this country gets any credit for the
amount of input they have on the triple
a development C and I feel like so many
people think that I would China they
make mobile games no dude they work on
every [ __ ] game you play this says 65
of our choices employees spent over two
years building eleven of horizon's 32
enemy robot types did I say Anna B I
don't know what my mouth was doing
modeling many of the bandit settlements
spread across the game world that's
significant and the kicker here virtuous
was only one of 18 different outsourcing
companies that worked on the game among
the others three lateral studio in
Serbia territory studios in New York
audio motion in London koku in Brazil
and an ex parte Santa in Taipei who
built environmental assets I mean I
guess my main point here is just video
games are way way way more global than
you think and there's a really good
reason for this the reason is they are
too hard to make locally it's too
expensive for developers to make Triple
A games solely in the US
at this point it would take too long or
be too expensive you can't see every
game here but uncharted 4 dying light
others now
these sources are a little bit out of
date but a 2001 study found outsourcing
contracts were too small and half has a
dementia measure what the [ __ ] but by
2006 40% of game studios were using out
sources with background or environmental
art in 2008 an anonymous poll of 200
major video game studios found that 86%
relied on outsourcing of some aspect of
development 86% that is majority of our
industry today the practice is so common
that many game studio is created
full-time coordinator positions to
manage outsourcing basically this is a
huge thing it is so commonly used and
not often spoken about though you will
often see it in the credits they don't
hide these credits in video game credits
sentences and it has not always gone
well hobbsy team had to apologize for an
inappropriate female model on a test
server basically that happened that's
how it's meant to look that's what
happened they kind of say without
sourcing you have to make sure that you
very closely look at everything to see
if there are any memes that have slipped
through swastikas maybe any kind of
political commentary or just human
genitals because sometimes the teams
working in China or whatever other
country is being used for outsourcing
may not care as passionately about your
project as the people in the main
headquarters of the studio might so
coming back to the corona virus I guess
I've been trying to paint a picture of
how much the video game industry really
does depend on Chinese companies to
assist them in making video games the
outer worlds switchport
being delayed is obviously because of
the corona virus but I have zero doubt
and have confirmation from two other
development teams who have spoken me
anonymously and I'm not allowed to
confirm which video games have been
delayed because of the corona virus
because people are not able to work
that's one
even getting into the film industry
China funds so many films and video
games that you see so many things
changed but Chinese markets that you
think would be changed for the US market
but often are not I feel like this has
been spoken about recently but the monk
and dr. strange was originally supposed
to be Tibetan but the Chinese government
did not want them to use reference to
Tibet so they became a different kind of
monk there are no witch doctors in
Diablo immortal which I would bet money
is because the Chinese market doesn't
like black people for the same reason
that fin is so small in the star wars
posters that released in China you've
probably heard of 10 cent and I might
make like one huge video detailing 10
cent at some point robber than just like
bringing them up occasionally every now
and then but 10 cent is a giant Chinese
company that is invested in so many
assets of entertainment that they may as
well be running the show and I know that
10 cent make demands like yeah you can't
have any black people in this we don't
want them before funding this you can't
do that Batman characters gotta be white
or Asian for the Chinese market
basically just a lot of these decisions
aren't being made locally or being made
wherever the studios are actually faced
they are often being made by investors
in China all being held up or created by
teams in China who are working on these
games when it's the biggest country in
the world with the highest population it
kind of makes sense the biggest market
in the world is going to control a lot
of things I just feel like we often
forget that that's the thing and yeah
the longer the world is concerned about
the coronavirus the more video games are
going to be affected by this it's
possible that some games that we've
already heard have been delayed were
delayed because of the coronavirus we
just didn't hear that as the reason why
and I promise there are more coming
anything that affects China affects the
rest of the world so buckle up game is
your new worst enemy is the coronavirus
it's crazy that this is real but also
fascinating stuff a very good article on
the outline I'll leave a link to this
below if you want to read more it's
absolutely worth reading this whole
thing it's some very well-written and
when I was like I'm gonna make a video
about this and I came across this
article I was like thank you I can
highlight what you have said rather than
having to write this from scratch
because you have done a great job author
is Michael Thompson
nice work already friends I'm Ilana I
will see you guys next time